what's up everybody let's give you some
dates here i'm on tour check
savilecanoncomedy.com for everything uh
the 26th and 27th i'll be in february of
madison uh wisconsin to barrymore and at
the chicago at the vic on the 27th um
may 21 and 22 san diego and los angeles
los angeles a big one at the wilton uh
and then these new ones just announced
and they're all on sale right now i got
louisville and evansville april 15th and
16th tulsa and oklahoma city april 23rd
and 24th rochester and syracuse june
10th and 11th milwaukee and minneapolis
june 17th and 18th and then hampton
beach june 24th there you go baby oh
chattanooga march 12th because me and
you are march 11th at the ryman theater
in nashville tennessee and then
chrisdcomedy.com this friday rescheduled
february 26th borgata i think both shows
are sold out are almost sold out so
thanks for coming let's even get some
ticky wikis march 4th royal oak detroit
march 5th gramercy uh
special taping new york city uh march
11th ryman and then march 18th and 19th
we got the more theater and the rev hall
in portland and seats and march 25th at
the win in las vegas folks today's
thursday tomorrow i'm in madison and
saturday i'm in chicago come the [ __ ]
out
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed
that you're all over what is it
hey
hey babe goodbye let's do it okay all
right let's start
no no no no no no no no no no no
hey
babe
goodbye
what's up everybody hey babe mark
norman's here folks
welcome to lunch we sang that when my
grandmother died we called her nana so
we just went
good bye
yeah the other side of the family at the
funeral was like what the [ __ ] jesus
how'd she die uh
fentanyl
i thought you said fat and old
well that too right
mark norman folks from youtube special
out to lunch everyone's following your
model now now i'm putting out a special
on youtube sal's probably gonna do
special on youtube too hell yeah
baby this month alone you're going to
have
brendan schaub uh i think tim dillon
myself um all dropping on youtube
because you know really yeah because the
even even even netflix now i mean i
would love to do a netflix but even
netflix they only promote it for about a
month and that's it it's a big grab bag
it's lost on the shelf youtube is hey
it's up there baby it's the top of your
youtube page and what a great special
and look you watch mine then if you fall
asleep it rolls over to yours and it
rolls over to yours it rolls over to
tim's it rolls over shane and now we're
all helping now we're all helping out
nice that's good baby yeah man so um
your first time is this have you been on
staten island before many times i used
to do cargo cafe back when sal bartended
and you'd be like hey uh you know i got
this little improv group cooking a
little troupe and we go yeah yeah keep
pouring the drinks there
boom two weeks later you were famous
there it is yeah and i always remembered
how he treated me
did he treat you good mark mark always
treated me good from day one no we would
do a show in the back room and he was
the bartender it was a nice piece of
[ __ ]
oh they're out there yeah i think i
can't think of anybody i think everybody
legitimately so many people that are
comments right and all people that
stopped being comedians were at the car
because i did it for three four years
every every single week it's still there
you guys would come take the ferry and
then just close it out yes you'd be like
all right that's what we're doing
tonight exactly because you know you're
on the island your night's over but we
get blackout drunk because comics drank
free and then you just wake up and
you're at home you're like [ __ ]
my [ __ ] hurts i don't know what
happened and here i am at home yeah i
mean a lot a lot of late nights a lot oh
yeah like he would be there like once a
month yeah and you're like yeah i got
this thing the tenderloin's like yeah
whatever there
that'll last and now it's now it's but
uh you know now it blew up and then and
then uh mark you got your own version of
the tenderloins and we might be drunk
with sam morrell yes yes hotpot you guys
have both been on that's coming up we
did it back to back we did that that's
right
i get there at six o'clock to do your
pod we might be drunk and i'm like hey
that's a familiar voice and it was sal
and they're getting smack drinking
japanese whiskey yeah and then i came in
and drank a martini yeah and that was it
was amazing dude what a great night we
got sloppy together and then we all went
to the gramercy and oh yeah sold it out
and did ourselves a nice new york isn't
that a nice new york day a nice great
night we got to realize we're doing
great we [ __ ] and moan that guy kanye
west is crazy pete davidson is dead but
we got to remember that uh things are
good things are good it's pretty cool
having a day like that right great day
you have your own podcast in your own
space
and you you hang out with friends and
get and drink we all go through there we
all do the pod then all of us leave go
to a theater and do comedy sold out
theater what it is but we will complain
because we're on our phones like i
didn't get enough likes exactly how come
i didn't get the netflix special exactly
yeah yeah yeah no but that but we got to
stop doing that but i think we're i
think you mark and i started pretty much
the same time i think maybe a little bit
before me but we came up and opened
mike's together for sure yeah i mean
look at you know you used to be a
janitor yeah i was a physical therapist
yeah you look like an out of work
baseball player that's what it is
staten island baby yeah this house man
congrats this is beautiful i feel like
i'm on epstein's island there's a pool
back there
there's a lawn you got eight cars in the
driveway
but i'm not i'm not chad hanks that's
the thing i just would rather be chat
hangs you don't want to be that guy's
got a lot of problems no but look at
this bod well whoa that's [ __ ]
tom hank's son chet hanks is jacked
vanity chet hanks is hot right he's hot
he's crazy but he's hot yeah she's
saying he's cute he's kind of going into
american history x territory
he's going to curb stuff perfectly
why is he in the news now
um i i he said that he didn't have a
good role model growing up he didn't
have he didn't have a male role model
growing up he didn't his father isn't
that what he said pimpy isn't that why
he's in the tom hanks he's america's dad
he's america's dad
yeah he's america's dad or uh yeah tom
tom hanks sunchat claims he didn't have
a strong male role model uh grown up but
maybe tom hanks you know what i mean the
thing is is like i wouldn't be wearing
it tom hanks i don't know how good i
don't know if i'd feel
like secure with myself and my dad was
far as gump i'd be like you [ __ ] yeah
you're [ __ ] yeah come on dude
shut up dad right you know or
philadelphia tom hanks come on man aidsy
not to mention he's off on an island
living it up with a volleyball yeah i
mean i'm like maybe cause the thing is
here's the thing man when you're an
actor like that like it looks good for
these guys but i i would imagine tom
hanks was never home how could he be
never gonna film you're filming on
location for four or five months exactly
they didn't have face time back then
well on bosom buddies he also played a
trans agenda or a crossroads that's
right
maybe when he was younger he was off
with peter uh the other guy remember in
the beginning of the pandemic everyone
went nuts because he was the first one
to get covered and then everyone said
that he was a pedophile um tom had a
pedophile
tom hanks was a pedophile no no no no no
allegedly
tom hanks is a greek citizen they said
it was a greek
pedophile they're touching that's what
they said but pedophile has nothing to
do with it so there you go
there you go i regret tweeting that i
was drinking
yeah so jessica hill no relation to
jonah but you're right my dad was an
ambulance chaser and he was never home
so imagine forrest gump uh
running around never around but uh the
other hank's turned out uh he didn't say
that the other hank who's the other
hanks
who's colin he's the cute one he's the
one
no i think chet is my kind of guy he
looks like thomas i know he's definitely
no chit i like chet chet i like listen
if you have a tattoo on your chest i'm
in that's what chad has oh yeah and he
talks with the uh jamaican accent
doesn't he chet hanks does yeah
interesting and there's another one
truman hanks truman can you play the
chet hanks uh jamaican uh diatribe that
he does it's it's you want to feel
uncomfortable yes let's do it and he's
being dead serious
he's done it more than once that was
worse than the pedophile headline
jesus
also he's had some uh chili fritos you
can tell those lips
that was brutal and it's not he does it
more than that
it's bold bold
yeah you can't accents i mean
little by little they're going out of
style i think we're in a time too where
you're not even able to do like an
italian accent because like when you say
like oh it's a meet the ball nobody
cares about that no no but jamaican or
other ones you can't do chinese but i
think it's going to start to come where
you just can't do them anymore but
they're great yeah thank you very much i
mean it's all funny you ever see uh oh
yeah what's better bill hater on snl
when he did that vinnie vader thing yeah
no so it's it's italian gibberish but it
sounds so good because he has the
cadences and he's smoking cigarettes
he's like
and it's it's supposed to be italian
pull it up and it's really really funny
yeah but again
nobody cares white they're white dude
how about this i did a podcast uh the
one time i met bill hader so i had
you know
10 years ago right i had flirted a
little bit with with amy schumer on on
twitter and i dm'd her i dm'ed her i
said i said let's go out you know like
whatever talk corresponding a little bit
i said let's go out i want to buy you
some i want to buy you some freaking
ravioli tonight that's what i said right
then train wreck comes out or one of the
movies
yeah and then bill hader's lying to her
is let me give you some ravioli i want
to buy some ravioli tonight so i said to
bill hader i said you know amy wrote the
book i'm sure using experience whatever
how do you like that and then and then i
said to bill hey one time i know i said
i said hey you know that ravioli line i
said i'm the guy who dm'd her that line
he goes no you did and i made that up i
was like
i was like all right bill now i don't
like you anymore now i don't like you
because it's like don't be a [ __ ]
hack you're a hater hater you're a hater
hater yeah haterade you're a bill hater
i'm a bill hater
right now
if you're listening which we know you
are i'm challenging bill hader to a
celebrity boxing match nice because of
the ravioli
just to keep safe imagine i couldn't
even sell that out
now what what does the odds you think
that he did riff that
probably good i mean you know what i
mean well it's a pretty specific
possibility but why would he why would
he why would he lie i don't know if he
lied maybe he'll hate her he also didn't
know who i was he might have just been
like i don't know who you are get out of
my face that's possible too he had no
clue you're like i i dm yeah yeah yeah
also it's very kind of out out the
pocket for me to just come out and bring
that up to him there was no reason for
me it's like who do i think i now i i
want to be known as the ravioli line guy
like it was a little imposing on me and
a little uh insecure on my part yeah but
i still the fight is still up you know
if you want to fight i think we should
we got to make that your catchphrase
let's let's put that in cement as yours
what friggin ravioli
yeah what are you up to friggin ravioli
my merch gonna say friggin ravioli yes
now um uh oh sal's phone just went off
birth control it's built control imagine
it's bill
oh my god the fight's on
ravioli hater
um
so how about this are you following are
you keeping up with it julia fox kanye
west what's the latest what's the latest
so julia fox is now saying she was in
love with kanye west and used him for
the hustle before claiming he wanted her
to glamorize their relationship in the
press while trying to pursue kim
kardashian so pimp and pam is really the
one who first discovered this
julia fox is a performance artist and
was dating kanye as art right it's like
an nft this is like she did like a live
nft dating kanye right is that what
we're figuring out we understand because
they're not together anymore now julie
no when she said she's preparing a book
and she only loves her husband and her
child that's the only people wait she's
she's been married
her father and her child no she hates
she hates the ex i think ah got it her
dad her dad not her baby her father wait
wait wait this just came out yeah
they're not together julia foxy
they broke up on valentine's day
yes because because kanye because kanye
tweeted i miss my family
well she's gotta give him that and also
she came out that it was performance art
and i'm writing a book but you you found
this out before it hit the news
we heard you knew about this pips
[ __ ] got an
you know what my last relationship my
left shoulder she was performance r2
was it yeah i wanted someone to dump me
and streaming like [ __ ] there's
performance art but didn't talk
definitely
yeah it's performance
yeah this is like kind of she trolled
him with her genitals
oh
we're playing fast and loose with these
terms now troll
[Laughter]
allegedly
but she wrote she wrote online
everything she wrote was [ __ ] how
she was into him
that was according to her but this isn't
her way of saving face you don't think
what do you think and selling a book
based on when tia is shaking her head
yes yeah she i saw her with those birken
bags
yeah is that performance
allegedly the burking bags are like 400
grand a bag and he bought 10. what wow
that's what they say what yep a 400
grand a bag that's what they're saying
and he bought 10 of them what is in
those what what do they make those bags
with how how disrespectful if i was a
billionaire i wouldn't buy one of those
bags it's it's disrespectful well the
little kids in asia to everybody oh oh
does it come with a little the kids make
it are they making it
yeah how much is that 400 grand you
think that kid's making from that bed
no i don't know what's up here man well
this is this is kanye west today this is
more what he's going out more kanye's
he's off the reservation this is two
weeks all this news by the time this
comes out but just know that this is
happening in real time right now kanye
west just instagrammed a video of pete
davidson from five six years ago on snl
saying this boy thought he could get
away with performing the sketch for the
team that wrote this for him this is not
harassment this is payback that's what
he said
what is the sketch i don't get it uh
he's just making fun of kanye's mental
health issues right
here's ugly yeah years ago he might try
to kill him this could be tupac biggie i
really i feel it
well wow
here we're the comics so we we pete you
have a you have your safe haven here
also i i you know tt jerry's been
staying over so kanye can try to get
into this house but will be executed by
tt jared yeah yeah
tt jerry will protect pete davidson he's
on our side pete he's a staten island
boy he's a staten island boy
so he's with us kanye might fit into the
neighborhood with the maga hat though
you never know
that's a good point too
that's a good point too yeah that oh
that would stump the staten island
exactly
but he's black yeah
that's a tough don't go like that
what do you do what do you think the
public's landing with the feud
i love most are on pete's side i think
most right yeah
because congress looks insane he looks
so nutty but we've all been there we've
all been a little nutty over next year
yeah but kind of released this is uh
this is next level what's the worst
thing you've done for next oh well i
don't have the followers that kanye has
but you know you wait outside the house
with the boombox in the rain and a movie
stole that idea from me but yeah yeah
john cusack that [ __ ]
calls drink it up please come back you
know and then they play the voicemail on
oh man when i was my first my first
girlfriend first love situation i was
like late high school early college and
we dated for a few years and then we
broke up i didn't want to break up i was
heartbroken yeah and i was so sad and i
used to deliver pizza she lived within
the range in the neighborhood that i
delivered pizza in oh boy
so when i was done i went to our house
and i uh i was sad i was a young kid and
i was sitting outside in the car i was
crying yeah and i was like do i ring the
bell do i talk to her
and i saw the light was on so i i think
she saw me she came down and i had a
sony discman this man right and i'm
listening to these sad songs and i'm
kind of crying
and uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah i don't know you can hold a note
hey thanks i'm very talented
i forget what the song was i i it was
really sad though yeah i think it was a
it was the oldest song in that oh okay
it's like like one of our parents it was
like an older one like uh like um
what's that song by james ingram i've
talked about before it makes me cry
it's uh it's uh
i gave my all
but i guess my oh it wasn't good enough
because here we are back where we were
[Music]
i miss you cheryl just once
you're bringing me back sal yeah i miss
you melania
how about this
got our 450 grand uh ticket to space
that's how much it cost for virgin
galactic opened up ticket sales to the
puppy wobby 90-minute space flight cost
you 450 or get a birkin bag get a
barking bag your choice now is con kanye
i mean he's going to who's going to take
the space flight and do we think this is
going to end in disaster
what do you think i hope not but it's it
seems possible right he could get ugly
it could be a physical he could show up
to where pete's at and no no no no i
meant
sorry space flight
can i bring my service dog that's the
question that's a good question you
couldn't pay me to go on a flight to
space at all he couldn't pay me who do
you guys think the first comic in space
will be first comic con hopefully cosby
let's just shoot him up there
sleep the whole way yeah
all right
i think the fir if i had to guess who's
gonna do who's gonna go to space
who's has to be first maybe chappelle
he's maybe chappelle yeah yeah yeah yeah
you have to wear masks on that plane oh
good question probably not right
everybody's rich yeah right you probably
don't know no mass up there
this is a little like i mean i want to
go around a little bit you know click
now you would go in
someone offered to you for free someone
offered to you for free
i won't even skydive i'm a puss yeah
there's my ex
just once
oh wait so she comes out and i'm
listening to the thing and i'm crying
and i go i want you to listen to this
song
uh i've
just just listened to it i've just been
listening to it we were dating for years
yeah actually put it on and she she took
it off momentarily and she said i'm
sorry i don't like you this way anymore
oh
and how old were you i was like oh
elizabeth um i was uh i don't know 20.
cut two oh so you were old enough maybe
19. this wasn't bs
out of high school yeah we would date
for like 15 to like 19. oh that's big
well you were out of high school but she
wasn't
[Laughter]
cut to a video of all the jokers
laughing
florida mamaresa from giving meth to
teenage son but i feel like this is just
one that they picked this happens all
the time i mean it's hard to be you know
doing a little math graduation
presentation
you could tell instantly can't you yeah
yeah the tv instant it's like oh that's
meth totally right yeah it looks like
shitty coke would you would you mark for
at the end of your life let's say you
got what what drug would you want to try
that you wouldn't try now i would try
heroin at the end yeah you know just
like [ __ ] it everybody loves it i'm
dying anyway let me feel this let me
feel this
what drugs have you done oh come on acid
shrooms uh molly
fentanyl what's the favorite part what's
your most favorite podcast you've ever
been a guest on uh the life is short pod
with justin long my buddy wow really
that was good we got fun justin's the
best i had a very nice pleasant easy
conversation with him the hour flew by
uh it was really nice it was really nice
yeah because you know what it is with
justin is i listen to i listen to his
episode with rob riggle and he just like
digs deep and he goes like beyond what
you expect to hear in an interview show
yeah i mean
can we go to the top of that one buddy
just right here sorry yes yeah yeah i i
really like that and now which is kind
of cool we're having he's advertising on
our pod which i actually love he talked
to billy zane about uh being in the
titanic his hollywood career small roll
back to the future that was a great app
um and i like his interview style he
pulls out some unexpected stories uh you
know he talks about him being on
mcgruber um it's just you know it's it's
pretty awesome justin long is and i love
all his movies and it's like the thing
is justin i think is one of the most
likable people in hollywood so you'll
love his podcast it's really zane being
a macgruber yes billy's ain't being in
group sorry sorry yeah and titanic and
the titanic and my dreams so he just
justin's been around so long that the
guests that he have on are just a wide
variety of guests yes so that's what i
kind of like too like if someone's i'm
like i'm not that interested next week
i'm like oh my god i can't believe you
got this do me a favor go listen to life
is short with justin long on apple
podcast amazon music or you can listen
ad free by joining wondering plus in the
wondery app we love you justin
watch life is short all right policy
genius listen okay you know if you're
someone out there you rely on financial
support whether it's a child aging
parent even a business partner what do
you need life insurance babe that's what
you need i'm telling you they're not
policy genius they're not an insurance
company they're like more like an
insurance broker okay they help you shop
for the best insurance uh policies out
there which is huge it is your one-stop
shop to find and buy the insurance you
need click the link in the description
or head to policygenius.com
and answer just a few questions in
minutes you can compare personalized
quotes from top companies to find your
lowest price you could save 50 or more
on life insurance by comparing quotes
with policy genius policy genius doesn't
add on extra fees since 2014 they've
helped over 30 million people shop for
insurance and placed over a hundred and
twenty dollar bill and billion dollars
in coverage policy genius is your
one-stop shop to find it by the
insurance you need click the link in the
description or in the description or
head to policygenius.com and answer a
few questions in minutes you can compare
personalized quotes from top companies
to find your lowest price you could save
50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius the
team of licensed experts at policy
genius will help you understand your
options and apply for the policy you
choose the policy genius team works for
you not the insurance companies you can
trust them to offer unbiased help and
advocate for you at every step until
you're covered
they don't add on extra fees nope they
don't sell your info to third parties
they have thousands of five star reviews
across google trustpilot and since 2014
policy genius which is one word
lowercase g has helped over 30 million
people shop for insurance and placed
over 120 billion dollars in coverage
head to policygenius.com to get your
free life insurance quotes and see how
much you could save you ever do a low
blow never done blow interesting i don't
like the snort never done you ever you
ever done a little blog
really i never done anybody ever do
anything i won't do that nobody's ever
done any blow out there they have and
the other room that's it
i'm too scared of that too well i don't
want to get hooked because i think i
like it yeah
i don't know i mean what i have enough
you know you got weed you got alcohol
yeah i'm good i'm good with weed and
alcohol i i've recently been doing more
edibles
that i like i have a friend my friend i
just found this out i mean did any
wouldn't even take a sip of alcohol not
a sip of alcohol he's always overweight
250 300 pounds never a sip of alcohol
you know he's got a wife three kids he
must be early 40s now i talked to his
brother the other day goes you know my
brother lost about 150 pounds i said how
he goes he's been doing edibles for the
last year what don't they make you have
the munchies not him it's go it's just
calms him down to a place where he
realized like he was overeating because
of anxiety and the edibles brought down
his anxiety and now he doesn't eat how
about that i mean i eat an edible i want
to eat everything in sight same what do
you think elton john
oh yeah i just get high and eat
something yeah you see there you go
there was a thing coming out where like
somebody like seth rogen or uh what's
her name uh uh
blonde comedian uh she's like a drunk
that's a whole big deal she takes out
chelsea there was like she was
developing a weed that doesn't that does
not give you uh make you hungry it was
like a big thing i was waiting on it
her and joe coy are dating now pretty
serious
from to joe coy it's quite nice i like
it i like it who's after that well 50
cent to joe coy to maybe maybe she'll
make it with joe coy i hope so he's
killing it they look fine he does arenas
oh my god he's like a sleeper hit like
no one talks about him i feel like but
he's doing that's the best way to do it
exactly i don't want to be in the press
and the news i don't give a crap dude
god knows but i'll make a million
dollars a night justin trudeau who now
we are finding out there's no rumors
going on that justin trudeau is fidel
castro's son
that's the rumor going around the
internet that fidel castro's mother
and fa sorry justice judo's mother and
fidel castro had an affair and that's
why they think what's happening now in
canada is they think that's i mean you
know who knows
if it's true enough but elon musk just
tweeted uh he compared trudeau to hitler
because what's happening now in canada
is trudeau is freezing the bank accounts
of some of the truckers up in canada
we don't really get political on a babe
we're silly willy billy's but i will say
freezing a bank account is a little that
is very very very very that to me is the
scariest thing that's happened in my
life is that they're freezing a major
first world countries citizens bank
accounts why no why because the truckers
won't leave ottawa and i think what
happened is trudeau realized and the
canadian government has realized that
they actually cannot get them out the
police
because almost a lot of the police and
national guard are like we're with the
truckers we don't want these mansions
so trudeau is it's like it's almost like
people have said like if this was you
know if we weren't in civilized times
like they would it would have been like
marine internet they would have cut his
head off like in the public like the the
the country there was like nobody wants
because the mandates in canada are i
mean it's it's bleak over there i mean
you cannot do anything well they tried
everything they call them all right they
call them races they call them white
supremacists and that didn't work so
he's going for the bank account which is
kind of the jugular and then one of the
people in canada like a high up uh
news person there or i'm sorry member of
their parliament there said if also if
we see any pro-trump rhetoric on your
social media or whatever we're going to
freeze your bank account or alluded to
that so it's very scary times there gary
in canada authoritarianism a bit a bit
of authoritarian but they're saying it's
because trudeau is fidel castro's son
and you know what that is
that's friggin rigatoni
that's rigatoni look at that this is
yeah that's the pinky ring it's a
beautiful gift from the staten island
mall people have said i have the hands
of an old woman i could see that yeah i
gotta do it
those are like you look like a newborn
pig
that looks like a fresh pig
wait what is that mcdonald's
pink oof look at that same after five
years well hey teach me some aging
tricks will you i know dude i'll rub
that on my face exactly yeah jesus wow i
mean but i to be hon to be fair i
haven't eaten mcdonald's i don't think
mcdonald's makes as much money today as
it did 10 years ago i don't think so
right i don't think what's that somebody
had mickey d's
uh i don't know maybe like in the last
couple of years once you mark well i get
their cone i love that [ __ ] ice cream
that's what oh that's that's it that's
it i don't eat the the burgers just go
in there at mcdonald's and get an ice
cream and watch i eat it like a homo on
broadway i'm just walking around with
licking that thing and i love it that
should be the name of your next special
homo on broadway
that's actually kind of catchy i think
mateo oh wow i'm sorry
mcdonald's sales have soared this year
even though coveted restrictions remain
in place in many countries the last few
months jumped 40 to 1.5
wow you know what it might be first of
all everybody did edibles and then you
get the uber eats they deliver now
mcdonald's huh you just have to go in
there and feel the shame i was going to
say now it's shameless mcdo the ubereats
delivers to you everybody wants it but
i'm i don't want to go in exactly i
don't want to be i don't want to be
caught in a mickey d's that's very very
interesting smart maybe mcdonald's
called japan by the way that was 1.5
bill in the in the uk in euros so that's
not even that's not here though that's a
trillion dollars in u.s money now see
some people are saying kanye is a genius
because he's stirring up all this uh
hubbub because he's got a thing out now
sure which is he is and he
he does it all the time but he trended
above the super bowl the other day above
the suit and look at this he he jumped
1.5 million followers in three days wow
super bowl wow it is smart what he's
doing do you think there's any
i don't know
who knows do you think there's any
possibility that him and kim are in on
it and they're like this is to promote
albums
that's pretty that would be pretty low
she's good at this too though she's the
the other side of the coin who's the
best at marketing she is it's tough
almost every the last like three podcast
episodes three weeks we've talked about
this every show but it's different
things have you guys seen julia fox's
artsy photos oh she's a kook yeah she is
look at that oh
i was gonna say it looks like
there it is there's a mcdonald's
cheeseburger on the floor
holy [ __ ] that's the worst improv troupe
ever i know
these are the new and practical jokers
i'd watch that i'd watch that oh i'd
watch that right away yeah yeah i would
too actually you know you can't go near
that you can't go near that snow that's
still
[ __ ] still
and like you don't pimp you know you're
a photographer you can't just snap this
in a second they have to sit on that
snow for an hour oh this is pose and the
outfits they planned for weeks i mean
right but my point is not a quick oh get
on get off they were on that for a long
time oh no no no yeah they get the
perfect photo from there
walking down the city and someone's
doing a photo shoot yes and you gotta
like wait and you're gonna walk between
like sorry but it's i cringe so much for
the person that's posing in the middle
of the street like you know what i mean
it's always like oh it's too much it's
gross even worse is this like when
they're doing it alone i know oh what a
loser it it just feels like it just
feels so fun delilah when delilah was
two or three years old and i didn't even
think to get this but delilah we were in
the city and i know i bombed on the
jumbotron two nights what happened they
put me on the jumbotron nobody cared
uh but it was fun um one of the players
looked at me and he was like just gave
me a thumbs up this is the third or
fourth time i've been putting the
jumbotron and no one scared oh i was
supposed to okay
look colin jones looks terrible
this is i was asked to go to do i want
to do this because they'll promote it's
all within the garden beacon theater may
14th tickets are on sale right now
baby's doing two shows maybe you don't
know
it's up to you guys
saturday may 14. new york city beacon
theater on sale right now several county
companies.com get your tickets like it's
97. yeah call the venue wait online do
you ever wait online with a wristband no
you got tickets you would are you maybe
a two maybe you're not not but i also to
be honest with you here's my thing on
this and no judgment on people do me
personally i never want to wait online
for anything people want to wait online
for snl overnight sneakers not my thing
i can't love a person more than as far
as musicians go i love whitney houston i
love if they brought whitney houston
back from the dead and she was only
doing one concert i wouldn't wait online
for the tickets i'll say i'll see it on
youtube wow if i would like to walk up
and get i'd like to go to the venue sure
i would love to be at the show i'd pay
to be at the show but i can't wait on a
line i just don't want to do not one
part of me wants to do it yeah yeah i
hear you i get it but it kind of it kind
of makes it sweeter if you score it yeah
i mean you put the work in you know and
then you feel like oh i work to be here
but i get it i wouldn't wait you guys
ever gotten rooked by a scalper yeah
sure oh that's the worst my dad did my
dad paid money outside the garden yeah
and they handed him him handed him an
envelope and he and and then as soon as
the guy handed me the animal by then
the guy
started to run away my dad opened it
with coupons
how much did he give do you remember
i don't i don't remember if you go to
the game or event anyway though did you
just pay again then absolutely not you
went home yes it's soul crushing yeah it
was it was money were you mad at your
dad or the scalper i was meant to scalp
her come on i thought my dad was
hoodwinked yeah yeah what about you well
you could have but looked up at your dad
and been like i mean
aren't aren't you 30.
yeah i mean even i knew it was just he
couldn't run after him because i was
there
so then it's your fault it is my fault
yeah you carry that with you
i will now yeah you know i uh i people
were complaining to me that like people
write online like i'll tweet about a
show i'm doing like for example we're
doing the ryman on march 11th march
11th it out there venue so i'll i'll
tweet that and some people be like i
looked
225
no way buddy sorry pal too much i'm like
my tickets are 65 55 and 45
these are online internet scalpers
people reselling at that level and
people think that i'm charging no
control over this no not at all i don't
respond to them anymore
i don't know what you want me to say
just yeah i'm like absolutely right um
the tinder swindler signs with hollywood
agents i watched dating i watched it
was it good because i was told to watch
but we haven't gone through it it's
great he's five seven which is even more
wow yeah wait a minute he [ __ ] signed
with an agent the wait did you watch it
no okay he he literally ruined lives of
dozens of women took all of their money
right then he
he hopped around from country to country
so no country really had jurisdiction
since he was always on the move they
didn't apply resources to him it comes
out he was a full-on con artist right
that wasn't his name he didn't work for
where he said he worked for he swindled
all these women out of hundreds of
thousands of dollars
went to jail for forging a check for 15
months got released is not in trouble
for all of that they still carry their
debt he is released living the life
right now and dating a model it's any
and he's starting a podcast
but why is that surprising i mean do you
i mean it's the scum hollywood doesn't
give a [ __ ] they don't care they don't
kill anybody sign anybody the views they
want the viewers want the money they're
pieces of [ __ ] he's doing two at the
beacon
may 14th
yeah okay it's wild now if they if they
glamorize this guy and he gets a dating
show yeah we are really
going to [ __ ] it's better oh no it's sal
i don't think we can stop it it's
happening because people will watch the
train wreck it's happening it's gonna
get exponentially worse what's it gonna
be like are we gonna live in armageddon
times in like 30 years it's all falling
apart
all these news channels will just tell
you any news just lie it's all well i
feel like come to a head yeah every
movie every movie you watch has got some
armageddon theme yeah you know and to me
that's like holly you know like they
hollywood may think that it's always
connected
they think the cia runs hollywood right
it's all connected to get messages out
to the people subliminally yeah it feels
like that where it does you know every
movie you see is about some armageddon
earth tell him you know and i'm like
what is going to happen right now folks
i know who knows now when the end does
come what do you do oh i think you got
to hunker down and move to staten island
i don't think what it is i'm coming here
man yeah no mark's going to do a set on
the rubble
it's great i i i think though i think
that
there is a turn though now happening
where agreed five even five years ago if
you would have told me the news is lying
to me or the news that's getting views i
would say you're crazy no it's got to
get 50 million in there
and they tell the truth but now it's
like it's common knowledge about the
media being liar and them getting no
views of the joe rogans of the world are
i'm not saying they're the truth tellers
but that's where all the views are right
even my mother knows that now even my
mother will be like i don't i don't i
don't take what they say as fact anymore
yeah because
the curtain has kind of been pulled back
a little bit
it used to be we have no way to know if
they're telling the truth they're not uh
oh no trouble okay who do we just in
there
are we in trouble jazz or is that tt i
can't tell
oh the food's here oh the food
all right
i see my baby's foot and beautiful hips
that's a cute foot that is a cute foot
violet
my daughter are you gonna have kids mark
i think i might yeah once the
restraining order goes away i think i'll
do it we're going to your wedding yeah
[Applause]
did i get a plus one yeah i thought you
did yeah yeah we've got a couple pluses
bring the whole game what are we looking
forward to let's talk about it oh my god
it's in the french quarter oh it's gonna
be a bunch of comedians i got a lot of
fun people the food's gonna be real
creole we got a jazz band we got a rock
band we're gonna go out after and
anybody gonna do a set who's gonna do it
no sets i already got it scolded by my
friends so uh we could do a really nice
lineup at the same time
the lady already pepper sprayed me when
i brought it up but uh but i don't pay
for everything but what about the night
before though that's what i said yeah
cause it's on a thursday right it's not
on a weekend or is it on a weekend it's
on a thursday i did that so you guys
could still do the road after i'm about
yeah well you know i was gonna say you
know how many of us already called like
hey friday night we're trying to get
this theater that club we're all trying
to just [ __ ] so if you guys wanna
that's a good
why don't we do a wedding show on that
friday center your wife will kill you
well maybe i'll do a guest set but
should i see if i can do that
friday november 11. oh you'll take it
off with a honeymoon right after no no
no we'll be there we'll be live
[Music]
yeah we got tim dillon
florida woman jasmine martinez watch out
for the jasmines use pandemic loan to
hire hitman to murder rivals so they
used a ppe loan to murder
that's pretty good i think it's a good
use of it it's better than you know
doing that than making things is that
smaller picture the the the hit in
action you gotta be the rival
whoa she's a little jealous yeah
probably
wow yeah so so was the hitter up for
withdrawing 10 grand in the days for the
shooting after she needed 15 wow 10
grand for hit not bad not bad
yeah they're going down yeah i would
consider
uh
oh then they hit the three-year-old kid
oh the gunman actually killed the person
she killed she killed lashante jones but
they wounded her three-year-old son you
scumbag now i'm mad you know because
it's like the hint like i mean obviously
it sucks but who knows what the hell's
going on but you can't hit the kid
yeah [ __ ] you should get the electric
chair for that that's tough but they
didn't kill the kid they wounded the kid
okay that's a tough kid
with government money
with government money wow that's
something that is america
blue lives matter
holy [ __ ]
i saw this today attractive people have
better immune systems new research
reviews we all knew that yeah i mean
yeah of course that's why you're
attracted to that the thing is here's
the truth to the situation right i mean
you say what you want about it but
attractive people will just get more in
life in any field of course anywhere you
can [ __ ] and moan about that all you
want it's just it's a human condition
it's the ultimate privilege we talk
about white privilege all that it's it's
good looking is number one genetics
lottery how about this we learned me and
pimp went out to dinner with a um
like a big-time democratic lobbyist when
we did shows in dc thanks for coming out
to the warner theater aoc no well aoc he
but he you know he explained to us dc
how it's like just hollywood he said
it's hollywood for ugly people which we
thought is hilarious i think you know
greg that's so true but what he said was
was interesting he said you know
everyone talks about diversity with race
and you know mainly race he goes that's
that's that's for stupid people and this
this man was not white i think he was
indian he goes he goes that's for stupid
people he goes that's for like that's to
distract the masses oh yeah race
diversity goes that's all [ __ ] he
goes the truth is it's it's not race at
all he said what the real diversity
needs to happen he said every member of
the supreme court every prominent
position it's all nepotism he said in
the schools harvard and yale he said
everywhere you go it's you graduated
from harvard yale he said so it's
nepotism is a real problem he said
because that's it doesn't matter black
white asian chinese goes they they don't
see any color up there right he goes
it's it's that's what needs to change
you need to start getting people because
they said when i really when you go to
an ivy league school the education is
the same at nassau community college as
it is at harvard it's just it's just
where you get plugged in in life
and that's the thing that needs it's
it's nepotism it's like your private
it's like it's like um being part of a
um like a country club but it's college
and that's the thing that ruins the
country it's all window dressing too
they just say diversity like you go to
these netflix meetings and they go we
need diversity we can't have you host
the show you got to get a black lady in
there you go all right but then you look
around the room and it's a bunch of
white guys in suits yeah i thought you
guys cared about diversity what about
you guys yeah i know but yeah but it's
all like to appease [ __ ] but but
that's but that's what i mean you know
it is
well you're half party right yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're cuban right yeah yeah
yeah
i checked the box babe i checked the
box is fidel castro your father i got
fidel in my family do you yeah castro's
in my family what a character lineage of
castro's in my family oh stop how do you
feel about trucking
i'm completely
such a small joking i was like wow chris
looks like the only guido magician
i know
i'm pulling like sacks of cash out of
that
fake vaccine
i can make this body disappear
[Music]
the great rigatoni ah
dad faces jail time for shutting down
town's internet to cut kids screen time
i like it oh good dad that's a good the
whole tears
how do you cut down the whole town
wi-fi
in prison for this what this has to be
canada no
oh a french dad a little french [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] we
wait disconnect how do you disconnect
the town's internet with
where do you a scrambler
scrambler they should hire this guy
yeah
everyone in town is like everyone in
town went out everyone's internet went
out everybody and they just like put
this guy in jail for six months i i
couldn't order [ __ ] national
frequency agency they just make up
[ __ ] agencies right the national
frequency agency shut up france i like
france just because of how much they
helped in the colonial war but it's all
like we wouldn't have a country without
them that's just the truth but i kind of
i'm i've had enough of french people you
know only speaking french to americans
being snobby it's like just shut up you
know what i mean are you still still
upset from eating that snail
yeah i had escargot for the first time
ever in
d.c it just was butter and garlic and i
don't like snail i it just it was too
chewy we ordered it someone ordered it
no we ordered it as like a goof we got
peer pressured we got peer pressured
into eating it by the lobbyists was it
all slimy and disgusting gross
and you know to be honest it's like you
know you tell yourself it's it's good
it's it's not you know what i mean and
it's not why is it expensive because
france and french want to act like
[ __ ] you got to pull them out of
there it's a special snack but it's a
snail well look at lobster lobster with
slave food
rebranding and now it's uh same thing
with avocado you know avocado was like
all you know perfect white
oh health food for most of in george
washington's times is a dessert
avocado's a dessert everywhere it's
tough it is multifaceted that's true
they put chocolate on it they're like
this is a it's like you guys are eating
cake for breakfast but it's like oh it's
a healthy fat it's like it'll give you
kidney stones so we talk about that
there's did we talked about the avocados
it's like the the blood diamonds yeah
the blood diamonds and that's right
avocados are like as bad as blood
diamonds people get killed
yeah yeah wow
these white girls eat their avocado
toast people are dying
toast baby damn every time you eat avo
toast it's the good fat though it's the
good fat
somebody somebody loses a loses
a life yeah they do they lose a life in
greece and italy snail are often
consumed in a variety of meals and
sometimes they are used in sauces and
poured over various types of pasta okay
later some started to farm snails to
sell them yeah dude it's uh
dude you ever you ever go i went to this
place it was fantastic it was a candy
store
in west virginia okay it was this place
called harpers ferry west virginia which
you haven't been is the most beautiful
town i've ever seen in my life it's like
you're in jurassic park the mountain
it's it's crazy dude like harpers ferry
west virginia it's i i can't explain to
you google a picture of harper's ferry
west virginia well yes okay
yeah wow there you go i feel better
about jerking victoria's secret now has
a down syndrome model now is it
downstairs hey listen inclusive and
she's beautiful not bad not bad very
pretty are those real or fakes what do
we think well those titties ain't that's
an old thing
yeah that's fine that's from uh
that's from
memories
pimp's gonna be wearing those glasses
soon i think
wow there it is she does look a little
like homeless pimp
so good for her good for her yes i
wonder if she's got strength can she
lift a car
they're strong people that's what i hear
it's great they pay her in crayons good
for her
all right we'll cut that out no i say
clip it
all right um so what was i talking about
obviously you know what this podcast is
sponsored by better help online therapy
yes relationships take work i mean look
at us we're in a great we're in a great
we work at it homo erotica how do you
guys get along you don't think it's work
we work we just don't show it it's not
all about the sex with us
a lot of us will drop anything to go
help someone we care about we'll go out
of our way to treat other people well
but how often do we give ourselves the
same treatment do you give yourself that
same treatment sally i
as i get older i realize that it's
important to invest in myself i've been
doing things like self-care therapy
coaching and this falls right in line
with because i'll tell you what it's not
always easy to go seek that stuff out
but when it's right in front of you why
not try it you were talking about
investing in bitcoin i said but what
about the bitcoin in here that's right
and that's what you invested in now and
now you you're doing so good and listen
whether it's hitting the gym making time
for your haircut or even trying therapy
you
my friends are your greatest asset so
invest the time and effort into yourself
like you do for other people okay now
yeah and i do i i do take therapy and uh
i think it is like going to the gym for
your mind i think it's a necessity i
think that people who think it's
something there's something stigma with
it that's completely antiquated thought
everybody should do it it's mental
health better help is online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to give it a try and see
why over 2 million people have used
better help online therapy this podcast
is sponsored by betterhelp and hey babe
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
hey babe that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
hey babe
oh come on baby you know we love to eat
we love what do we like to do when we're
eating food when i say let's order some
lunch what do you automatically say to
me dee dee babe store dance door dash
it's the only one i'll say what do you
want to eat tonight maybe you want a
favorite app on my phone it literally
door dash i mean it's the only app on my
phone it's like the colors wearing off
because i'm constantly hitting it i love
door damage so much you get what you
want to eat right now right to your door
along with restaurants you love you
could now get groceries that's a big one
other essentials delivered with doordash
you get drinks snacks household lineups
all in under an hour craving late night
snacks ice cream forget one thing for
dinner or maybe you just need to stock
up for the week doordash you could do it
all with the app they got 300 000
partners dude you can get cheesecake
factory door dash to your house i'll say
also popeyes in chipotle but cheesecake
factory doordash right two two cops you
don't have to go to the factory anymore
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 a limited time our listeners can get
thank you
25 that's vente cinco percent off and
zero delivery fees on their first order
of 15 or more when you download the
doordash app and enter the code hey babe
that's 25 off up to a 10 value and zero
zero delivery fees on your first orders
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter code hey babe
don't forget that's code hey babe 25 of
your first order with dorje s doordash
subject change terms apply
uh the most population
google harpers ferry west virginia yes
no because this is all about it's all
about marketing right yeah let me tell
you something about harpers ferry west
virginia first of all they went look i
mean look at this place
looks like medieval it looks like you're
in freaking switzerland you're in west
virginia yeah why would you do a gig
there or no i well yeah actually yes i
had done a gig in a part of virginia and
when we were coming up the guy who
hosted the gig was like you have to
you're going to pass right by harper's
ferry you know you love history take a
listen to where robert e lee first came
on the scene and wow uh this guy john
brown who's who like you know was like
big in the civil war with kansas
and so he was also on the white rapper
show john the one yes
so harper's fairy though they have a
candy store in there where they they
make candy the way it tasted in colonial
times and it is d
disgusting
[Music]
and it's cool but a candy to them used
to be to catch live you know like
grasshoppers kill them put chocolate all
over them chocolate bugs that's what
they would eat but there was no sugar
the way we have sugar now it wasn't
invented yet then so the thing is is
like if they ate they were saying if
they ate like a piece of candy today if
somebody like they might die like their
cyst it might be poison to their system
right because they it's like it's just
chemicals coming at them and their heart
might be too fast they'll have a huge
heart attack but wow this is uh it's an
interesting thing and then west virginia
you know everyone's like oh west
virginia hicks
we learned there i learned there in west
virginia
they when they change blue ridge
mountains
so west virginia what happened was is in
the beginning of the civil war north
first to south they
they uh were fighting with the south the
civil war the west virginia was fighting
with the south they wanted slaves or
whatever and then
uh uh west virginia said you know what
we changed our mind in 1863 they said
you know what we're secede we don't want
to actually fight for the south where
we're going back to the north so like
god had a friend like that in high
school no i know slave no slaves why it
is
so when they went back to the north
lincoln brought them in and lincoln said
you come in no problems we're not gonna
we're not gonna hold the [ __ ] against
you come and fight with us yeah and you
know obviously you know slavery is
outlawed so that's it it became a free
state it became a union state and then
with that the confederacy started a big
slander campaign against west virginia
saying your hillbilly your brother your
[ __ ]
sister the dumbass that's where that
came from none of it is true west
virginia actually one year i think in
the 90s produced the most ivy league
graduates in the country came from west
virginia yes so this is this whole idea
of them being these hick idiots is not
true at all i love it slander baby see
this is not new this whole internet
headline
now no the the first thing never go
viral uh
it was a lie the declaration of
independence [ __ ] lie thomas paine
this guy made a common sense it was the
first thing over he made up [ __ ] to
try to get the revolutionary soldiers to
stick around he made up [ __ ] he's
like yeah let's go freedom from england
and they were like what freedom from
england we're just fighting to get
represented in parliament in britain
they're like no you want to be free
don't you they're like all right [ __ ] it
and it went viral and then all of a
sudden next thing you know we're like we
want to be free from england most of the
people at that time were like why would
we want to be free from england they
[ __ ] didn't give up
they didn't want that at all
how do you collectively as a state
decide you're going to switch from the
south to the north
back then is people just like are we
doing this are we going to like you know
i mean like it's
a collective change your opinion
well and basically the bit like that's a
big deal
one way and then i think president
abraham lincoln at that time was
offering them uh money too he was
offered money and forgive their debts
they won't you know like they will be
able to uh uh actually you know what i
said they bought the racism out of them
well no i think the little caveat i
think a little baby caveat was is that
when west virginia went back to the
north even though they were in northern
union state i think they let some like
the really rich i think they let them
keep their slaves and they were like
don't look at that
but i think that's the thing for lincoln
yeah because the south by 1863 was
pretty [ __ ] clear the south was
getting their asses handed to them sure
because a lot of people think it was a
fair fight it wasn't it was like 500 000
union soldiers first like 80 000
confederates it's just the confederates
and the south still to this day were the
best soldiers like ten times better
soldiers i mean even today when we go to
war who is it it's all [ __ ] crazy
it's all the south yeah that fights so
they were the fighters back then as well
but we were like guys you know we were
bankers guys in the closet you know
[ __ ]
sherman's march to the sea you know to
tecumseh sherman his march to the sea he
was a [ __ ] banker he literally was a
banker you will be tested at the end of
this
yes
that guy was [ __ ] owned a bank in san
francisco he was a you know he was queer
he was he was he was over he was lgbtq
i have it all except happiness uh we'll
get you there all right well speaking of
happiness i got i'm happy for tom brown
i'm happy for tom brady as well well tom
brady they won the super bowl last year
they won last year they won in tampa
which is where he played he was the
oldest guy in the nfl took it home took
it home and i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention patrick mahomes yeah for all he
did and also this year matthew stafford
also in his home stadium los angeles
rams
off if i didn't mention uh homeless pimp
look like joe burrow joe burrow of the
cincinnati bengals scrappy team they
have a bright future ahead of him that's
what it is baby who's your team norm in
the saints go saints go saints great
unis black and gold good uniform bad
team good you it's so funny because like
you got the new orleans saints cool
uniforms cool team and then the pelicans
is
which makes sense because it's you know
new orleans birthplace of jazz and they
went to the whitest [ __ ] city on the
planet
should be the utah polygamists yeah
exactly the mormons don't you ever go to
a
growing up did you were you old enough
when you used to go to like the uh
what's that mardi gras oh mardi gras was
great i never went to a saints game as a
kid or a jazz game or a hornet's game my
parents didn't believe in any of it but
you participated in the monty mardi gras
was free and it would just walk down the
street so we'd get drunk at as youths
and uh catch beads and make out it was
great all that stuff it was a great
match but you got two weeks off school
for mardi gras
shut down i mean it takes over the whole
city it's the biggest deal and kids are
drinking and making out you can drink
outdoors there unbelievable to this day
could drink outdoors yes wow yeah i was
gonna because mardi gras was it
cancelled because of covet last year
yeah that was the first i've ever is
this the first year it's back oh it's
back baby when is it easter when is it
yeah around then
it ends on lent so i guess it's around
easter
two weeks long my first marty was three
marty's ago yeah i went and i got to go
on a float and everything whoa yeah and
it was something else it's a wild type
you got a drink because it's a it's an
excursion
connects or how do you get on a float
what do you mean connects like you have
to know somebody to know somebody get on
a float you have a float connection i i
have the guy the guy you have a float
guy i have the guy for mardi gras they
can't have never been on the floor very
conic junior i've never been it's a big
deal oh harry connick junior he gave us
all on float whoa
he's parade yeah yeah we we went right
with him i was with him do you remember
it was it endymion was it bacchus
it was bacchus oh boxing it's the
biggest one the last one bacchus is
every night there's a different head
head braid leader or whatever oh yeah
and they have there's not one wizard
yeah that's exactly there's not one
parade which i didn't realize there's so
many parents hundreds hundreds you've
got to go to a good one city but the
main one is down this french quarter
right yeah yeah well endymion is the
biggest i think and that goes all
through the whole town we went it was
hours on that thing it's out and we had
people handlers they we had boxes of the
beads yeah go and start drinking dancing
then we pulled right into the convention
center yes everybody in there is in
tuxedos wow this is my dream as a child
you got to deliver it's unbelievable
we've pulled through and they're paying
like crazy money a tick at a table yeah
and you and the circuit the parade goes
right through them eating dinner yeah
you park in the convention
you park in the convention center he
pops out gets on stage full concert oh
full concert
in the middle of it all and i'm sitting
i'm leaning on the piano wow
it was unbelievable
yeah he's the best he's our prince he's
so handsome he acts he plays music he's
the king of new orleans oh yeah he's up
drew brees was for a minute but uh yeah
it's always conic it's always nice ellen
won't claim us she's from new orleans
that [ __ ] lesbian she won't give us a
shout out then she got cancelled there
it is she doesn't rep no rep really yeah
12th night oh on january 6th is when it
was
the traditional that's what they should
have said oh we thought it was mardi
gras
the traditional beginning of mardi gras
is is uh january 6 of this year uh with
the first parades events slowly escalate
until fat tuesday itself but the
celebration is going anywhere from four
to eight weeks depending on when easter
falls so you kind of let the first ones
trickle out that's the weird stuff for
the riffraff and then by the end of it
the last two weeks are bananas
interesting yeah it's great one time in
atlantic city i was there and we they
had um they had this they had the miss
america parade but it's it's the parade
that they go down the boardwalk before
the actual miss america event all the
representatives from each state do a
parade where they show their feet it's
like the miss america feet parade they
have to show their shoe yeah google miss
america praying in atlantic city they
have to show their foot see sounds more
like the only fans parade i know and we
were there i was there and they were
like show us your feet like they would
like yelling and the girl and then they
go nuts and there was this one guy he
literally tried to like uh um i guess
like attack like one of the states like
tried to just grab her shoe and he got
[ __ ] fully arrested in front of us he
was like that guy from something about
mary right he was like just getting in
the shoes
and we didn't even know i was just there
to like i was just now i'm doing a show
i guess i don't even know why i was
there and we were like what is this yeah
and it was that parade dude it is the
weirdest tradition where they just
kicked their shoe up and these guys go
nuts guys had boners all around them
she was with us oh man
visible bones invisible boners and they
over footwear when it's like it's like a
cause because they know how to play at
the girls like you know miss cans will
be coming and they'll be going and
they'll do like that and they'll go like
that and they'd like come on come on
like they'll start yelling come on come
on come on and then they go like that
and they go
like it's a touchdown and then they'll
just like kick it up like it's just a
shoe no but they go crazy they wear like
all these it's the craziest tradition
it's like the show at your shoes parade
that's the name of it wow show us your
shoes and there and the guys show us
your shoes it was like
i'm not making any of this up this is if
you've been there you know if you're
from ac we and we just walked into we
had breakfast at uh you know one of the
air uh uh hotel breakfast and went to
just go on a walk yeah and we were like
what is this that's awesome
we were like fascinated by it yeah it's
correct it's like a leg hot guys they
snap they go crazy
fascinating you have a foot fetish this
is the place to be who gives a [ __ ]
about shoes yeah no they love it well
chris's house alarm keeps going off by
the way and we wanted some advice on how
to deal with intruders
i've my house has been broken into more
times than anything while you were in it
a couple times yeah in the middle of the
night like a lot of middle of the night
we had a big alarm system in new york no
in new orleans growing up my
neighborhood was so bad we had all these
horrible break-ins but uh you know my
dad would go out on a baseball bat but
we were broke too and that was the crazy
part like everybody would break into our
house and be like well this looks like
my house you know
the white family somebody thought we
were loaded because we had a big house
did you ever have to do your dad or you
ever have to like come face to face with
an intruder one guy was shit-faced and
he kept coming and banging our door and
my dad was like all right as a family
we're gonna have to tackle this guy oh
my god
oh my god so we're like okay here we go
and you know i was 14. my brother's 16
my dad's got a bat and we go out there
and it was a girl scout
so we almost
beat the [ __ ] out of her
she wouldn't have you found out at the
end
of the day
though that's like sergio sergio chicone
good friend of the show a guy works with
me on on all the roads sergio ciccone
tatted up you know puerto rican boxer
guy not scared of anything he was
telling me the story across the street
from his apartment
he was looking out the window it was
like three o'clock in the morning he
hears like a glass break like whatever
and he's like so you know he's his
apartment's all on one foot goes looks
out the window he's on a ground floor
apartment so he's looking he like peeks
through the window he sees this woman
like who's like on like she looks like
she's like possessed by satan he said
she was like like all crazy like boogie
on whatever he said she was doing this
thing where she was just staring like
out a window just staring with a hammer
right
this is three o'clock in the morning
she's just staring with a hammer right
she tries to like get in to like this
window like she said she would try to
get into the window open it open open it
and then just step back and then just
look out the window try to get open open
open and then finally she starts walking
down the street backwards like literally
backwards going
[Laughter]
he said sergio said that's the only time
in my life where he was like if she
would have come running towards my
apartment i would have left and i would
have ran away and left my family alone
he's like because she was he said it was
like demonic he's like it's the only
time i believe it i ever saw like like a
demonically possessed woman even him
telling me the story i like get like
goosebumps because he's like dude i was
terrified at first guy like sergio to be
terrified sure it's got to be i mean
it's it's either that or the police
sounds like pcp or something you
probably watch
i used to live in not a great
neighborhood in staten island when i was
little is that the name of it not a
great neighborhood yeah yeah
not a great neighborhood i've heard of
that town
and uh we live actually downstairs for
my grandparents right and uh one time my
mom was going out at night and this is
back when you have to like actually call
a cab company right so me and my sister
are down says my grandparents watches
their upstairs my mom calls the cab
company cab comes beeps right so my
mom's like all right guys i'll see you
in the military i'll be home kisses
goodnight she goes to walk outside opens
the door and then as she's opening the
front door to the house down the steps
it was like we were up like a lot of
steps outside the cab drives away so
she's like what the hell like i just he
just beeped
she's like what the hell so she gets
back up she calls the cab company she's
like yeah i called a cab the guy beeped
i was out there in under a minute and he
drove away and she's like what's the
address and he goes no some guy ran out
of that house and got in the cab
so we had a foyer before you get
announced we had a foyer and i guess
somebody was in in the foyer trying to
come into the house and when the cab
beeped in front of the house he knew
that someone was he the cat was waiting
for someone and he ran out jumped in
that cab and said take me somewhere she
goes no a guy is in that cab right now
and he came out of your address
oh
my god is that why i am i mean that's a
gift from god for the burglary but the
foyer was like let's say this is the
foyer this is the door outside our rooms
were right on the other side of that
glass the kids rooms no it was my mom's
room but it was like it was also like
connected to like the living room thing
and we were right there but there was
with shades down you didn't hear a thing
a thing holy scary right we had we got
broken into probably three times in two
weeks it was getting really bad they
were taking the tv the bikes all the
[ __ ] and they would tear your house up
that's the worst part about a break-in
is they they look for stuff
so
my dad said that's enough he called the
cop station the cops sent two guys down
they're like we're gonna sleep in your
kitchen
for
the night or not sleep but stay out
stakeout in the kitchen and we're gonna
catch these guys so i'm ten i'm like
this is exciting i'm upstairs i'm all
excited i'm thinking i'm gonna come
downstairs they're gonna cuff these two
guys who keep breaking in whoever it is
i come downstairs like seven in the
morning the cops had left they ate
everything in the [ __ ]
the kitchen was empty all the cereal
boxes were turned over the pop-tarts
they got it all they got it all yeah
nobody ever that's hilarious and they
never could you get robbed in the city
for a bunch of cash many times yeah
three times in a year got bugged in the
city
it was my fault not to not to victim
blame but i was in a blackout every time
okay
yeah so i was just like the white guy in
brooklyn like bouncing off the walls
drunk and easy targeting easy i was a
sitting duck like someone crawling your
apartment
um i thought i heard oh yeah that was in
the village that was in the village yeah
someone crawled in somebody opened my
window on the second floor in the in the
10th street in the west village and
nothing was gone
but i had a big drawer full of cash same
thing happening get out of here
every night after sets i just throw 20s
in 50s 100 and i was like one day i'm
gonna deposit that and i can't wait to
see how it is over years it was about
six grand oh i had a like a knife in
there i had shrooms i had weed i had
some pills all in there
i love a cool guy drawer yeah got a
sling shot and some porn you know and uh
he just scooped all the cash up took the
slingshot and the porn and got out of
there
came home from high school one day and
the cops were in front of my house and
the door was broke pushed in
and uh my dad i i went in i'm like what
happened he's like they robbed the house
i'm like who he's like i don't know i'm
like would they take everything was
turned over on all the floors the only
thing they took was cash out of the
drawer in my room that's it
no they threw all the things and then
later on my dad was investigating who
did it and uh
he had us he had a disagreement with the
neighbor
and uh we have it on good authority that
the neighbor paid someone to break in
and rob the house
wow
they caught my guy yeah yeah he they got
they did a [ __ ] fingerprint thing
they got one print months later the guy
robbed someone on the upper west side
matched the print wow yeah but they took
cash so he can't get it back
did you find anything out about him uh
just he was like a 56 year old black guy
he was old
right but he must've been pretty agile
to get in my window he had to climb the
fire escape and do all that [ __ ] and he
must maybe maybe he um would watch you
at the cellar and knew that we knew what
you were doing i know i posted my dates
i was like maybe he's a follower but
but my window is right next to the bed
it was a tiny apartment and he came in
through the window so he'd step on my
bed and every night i'd hear a tree
branch ah i couldn't sleep for like six
months because it [ __ ] me up terrible
yeah the violating it's so violating
yeah
i feel violated right now yeah well
i'll give you some money
plugs
oh geez yeah i'm at the beacon two shows
no i'm uh what am i doing
mark normancomedy.com i'm all over the
place so i got a ton of new dates we're
doing a theater tour we're cooking
check out the the website we might be
drunk tuesdays with stories out to lunch
on youtube and netflix half hour
whatever marching ornaments appraisal
babe you got dates yes
chrisdcomedy.com folks we got march 4th
at the royal oak in michigan detroit
march 5th gramercy theater new york city
two shows taping the comedy special
there really appreciate if you guys came
march 11th with the babe at the ryman
auditorium in nashville then march 18th
and 19th uh we are in i am in portland
and seattle and march 25th the win las
vegas oh my god you know your dates
let's say may 14th at the beacon again
because you can't say that enough
march 12th the day after the rhyming i'm
in chattanooga come see that april 15
louisville april 16 evansville april
23rd tulsa april 24th oklahoma city june
10th rochester june 11th syracuse june
17th milwaukee june 18 minneapolis june
24th hampton beach i'm thinking live pod
at harper's ferry huh whoa
very nice here it is
comedy.com this has been
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed